Yeah. So how do we make decisions using MRD in the modern era of treating ALL? So, of course,
all of us would like to have therapies that we can give. We cure our patients. We pat ourselves
on the back, move on to the next patient. However, all too often, there's residual disease.
And MRD is not a binary status. It's a spectrum of disease burden that is either detectable or
not detectable. And with increasing or improved technologies, we can reach deeper levels.
But at some point, you reach a threshold of detection. I won't go through all the data
supporting why you should use the highest sensitivity methodology for quantifying MRD
in ALL. But suffice it to say, you should use the highest sensitivity. But at some point,
you reach that threshold of detection. And you're still trying to guess, is your patient on the
green trajectory, meaning they're cured? Or are they on the red trajectory, meaning that they're
still going to relapse? So we have to take other factors into account when making this assessment.
And really, it boils down to their genotype. Because MRD is contextual with their genotype,
we have to interpret both together. Because in ALL, there are genotypes where if you reach MRD
less than 10 to the minus 4, as shown here, your risk of relapse is exceptionally low. But there
are other genotypes that if you reach that level of MRD, you still have 20% to 25% risk of relapse.
So we need to think about this as we're interpreting modern data. And there was indeed
a new paradigm for treating ALL that was presented with the ECOG-1910 trial, where adult patients
between age 3 and 5 were treated with MRD less than 10 to the minus 4. And there was indeed a new paradigm
30 and 70 with pH-negative B-cell ALL were treated initially with a asparaginase-containing
ECOG-2993 backbone regimen for induction and intensification. And then if they were MRD
negative, they were randomized to receive four cycles of blenatumab with four cycles of chemo,
or just the four cycles of chemo, and then go on to maintenance therapy.
And everyone is familiar with the Kaplan-Meier curves on the right side of the slide that show
those patients who got blenatumab for MRD-negative disease did extremely well.
And I think a lot of people didn't read between the lines and understand that this represents
less than half of the patients that accrued to the trial. So 40% of patients never made it to
the randomization. And as you can see here, only 46% of the patients who enrolled in the trial
achieved MRD-negativity, maintained MRD-negativity through the induction intensification and got
randomized. So everyone else is not represented on these Kaplan-Meier curves at all. The intention to
study outcomes have never seen the light of day. So we have to make a lot of inferences
on the basis of these data. For a short period of time, MRD-positive patients were also randomized,
and those patients who received blenatumab for MRD-positive disease did well. This was considered
to be confirmatory of the BLAST trial. And after blenatumab was approved for treating MRD-positive
disease, they needed to stop accruing to this arm. So the ECOG-Akron group did present this post-hoc
multivariate analysis to try and address whether transplant was useful for any of the patients on
the trials. Transplant was not a specified therapy. It was left to the investigators whether to use
transplant. And basically by random chance, 22 patients on both the blen arm and the non-blen arm
underwent transplant. And in this multivariate analysis, the use of transplantation did not
have a significant impact on survival. Only the receipt or not of blenatumab or performance status
or a risk category was associated with benefit.
So they took a little deeper dive and they show us on the left side, for all of the patients that
received blenatumab, there does not appear to be a benefit to receiving an allogeneic transplant.
And furthermore, on the right side, for the patients that had an unfavorable risk category,
if they received blenatumab, based on the numbers at the bottom, does not appear to be a benefit to
transplant. So we learn a little bit more as more data are released from this study. And Shira
is going to show you a subset analysis at IHA last year, where they only looked at the patients up to
age 55. So the ones that theoretically would be most potentially eligible for transplant. You can
see here that at enrollment, 53% of the patients had high risk disease. 66 of these patients had
pH-like disease. I'm going to come back to this number of 66. But we can see even in this younger
group, still 40% of the patients never made it to transplant and fewer than half made it to the
randomization and fewer than half were MRD negative and made it to the randomization.
And again, the dropout is because patients either didn't achieve or maintain remission for those two
cycles of chemotherapy, or they had excess toxicities. So for the patients that did make
it, they did very well with blenatumab, but we can see based on who got treated, who dropped out,
it's the high risk patients. So we go from 53% high risk at screening to 30% high risk at
treatment at randomization. So a lot of those patients, again, high
risk are not represented on these Kaplan-Meier curves anywhere. So chemo blend is not an answer
for everyone. They did do another sub-analysis looking at the B-cerebral-like or pH-like
patients. And they showed that for those patients who got randomized to blenatumab,
they had excellent outcomes. But this is only 19 of the 66 pH-like patients who were
enrolled at screening. So 47 pH-like patients dropped out because they could not achieve and
gain an MRD-negative remission. So they're not represented anywhere here. And on this Kaplan-Meier
curve, more than a third of patients got transplanted. So given all these caveats,
why is this even more impossible to interpret? Well, B-cerebral-like or pH-like disease is an
aggregate of more than 12 different genotypes based on gene expression profiling that makes
them look like pH-positive disease. But not all pH-like disease is created equal. This very nice
study from the MD Anderson group is a study that was done in the United States. And it was done
by a group where a third of their patients referred for pH-negative or for B-cell ALL have
pH-like disease. And we can see that amongst the pH-like disease, two-thirds have CRLF2 abnormalities
and they carry the highest risk, as you can see over on the right, for the worst outcomes. Whereas
the non-CRLF2 abnormal pH-like patients don't carry as much risk. So simply saying that B-cerebral-like
patients can do well with chemo and blenatumab doesn't really tell us how to make decisions in
the current climate. So we're going to look at the B-cerebral-like patients. And we're going to
go back to the clinical setting because we actually need to know, are they CRLF2-like or are they other
types such as abloplast kinase domain mutations? And why is this important? It's important because
we need to make the decision about whether to transplant. And transplant is the great equalizer
in B-cell ALL, even for some of these high-risk genotypes, including pH-like. You can see they do
just as well with transplant as the non-PH-like patients. And this is true for all of the subsets
of pH-like disease, including the CRLF2 abnormal patients. What other data do we have? We have a
study using blenatumab with a 10403 regimen in a very similar way. They have very short follow-up
of just over a year. And it looks fantastic. But look, they transplanted half of the patients. And
they didn't tell us how they applied transplant across different genotypes. So again, we're left
making inferences. The MD Anderson approach with hypercevad blenatumab is shown here. And I won't
go through all the details, but it will make a few points. These Kaplan-Meier curves are
intentioned to treat. So we know from the initiation of therapy all the way through what is the outcome
for these patients. And we can see on the right, those patients had one or more high-risk features,
do have a decrement in their survival. And Anderson, even though my friend Elias Shabor would
say he doesn't like to transplant ALL, they still transplanted a third of the patients on this
study. And so how do I put all these data together, taking all the caveats and trying to remove my
biases for transplantation and trying to really scrutinize the data? So for a standard and
objective approach, I think we can continue with chemotherapy, no transplant. If they're MRD
positive after blenatumab, they're going to have a problem. They can either go to a CAR-T cell if
they're still CD19 expressors, or potentially go to allotransplantation directly. For the high-risk
patients, we need to really scrutinize both their response to the chemo and the response to blen.
And that's a strict interpretation of ECOG 1910. Because remember, those Kaplan-Meier curves only
include people who were MRD negative after chemo before they got blen. So we need to really scrutinize
the blen. The blen was an immunologic consolidation for MRD negativity. So for the patients that do
well with chemo and maintain an MRD negative response, I think even if they're high-risk,
we can consider not taking those patients to transplant. I still have biases, as does everyone
else. I'm probably still going to transplant the KMT2A rearranged, probably still going to
transplant the CRLF2 rearranged until we have more data. But I do think that this is reasonable.
For patients that are MRD positive after chemotherapy with a high-risk genotype,
even if they become MRD negative after blen, I would not trust that to be a long-term remission.
I'm going to favor taking those patients to transplant. And for the patients that become
MRD positive after blen, whether or not they went to the blen, MRD positive or negative,
that's a patient that really has a problem. And again, I would favor taking them to a CAR-T-cell,
if at all possible, or directly to an allotransplant. So I'm two minutes over time. I do
apologize. That was very hard to go through in seven minutes. And I won't read my conclusions
because they're all encapsulated in the final figure.
And thank you very much.